alors est-ce qu'on pourrait serge
khalfon s'il vous plaît des c'est un
tout petit peu
voilà la lumière jean galant bouge pas
je vous faire une idée reniement sont
justement comment fait d'habitude à la
télé vous êtes prêt moustiques comme ça
vers la répondants montant oui c'est
difficile ça se regarde les l'air qui
l'a aidé à ses yeux bleus le bon dieu
sans confession
est ce que vous êtes content que le pacs
a été votée ça honteux je trouve que les
[ __ ] faut tous les tuer des gens
d'extrême droite moustiques abrite
toujours d'ailleurs je trouve que on
peut être homosexuel mais pas ceux de
déclarer est-ce que vous avez été
heureux est-ce qu'ils étaient heureux
benoît delépine que lagaf elle est élue
personnalité de l'année aux sept d'or
trouve seulement un vrai compte full tu
es aussi mais c'est l'interview mensonge
ça merde non mais moi je ne pense pas du
tout ce que j'aime bien j'adore la bague
à mon meilleur ami mais qui sait plus
votre émission favorite du mensonge
est ce que vous trouvez que ppda les
journalistes
oui la gauche
ils arrivèrent de ses 1 400 bloqués non
non mourir c'est notre truc c'est la
coke
si on avait d'ailleurs là je me sens
déjà maintes si on n'en a pas c'est
l'interview mensonge elle est justement
un bon d'accord on est clean mais c'est
pas possible d aller voter oui j'en ai
bonne classe de groland et des polonais
non mais nous c'est non on est très
clair c'est marqué dessus c'est du vin
du hb et du vin à nous excuser c'est un
art qui plus est pour vous la
dépénalisation de la torah interdit
mensonges en ce qui vous concerne je
suis pour une modification de la
législation puisque elle n'est pas
appliquée se dire qu'aujourd'hui
personne n'est poursuivi pour avoir fumé
du haschich en pratique
heureusement je suis en levant sa wii
cabane ccj ça peut arriver donc
évidemment le principe de l'interdiction
en soi peut-être compris mais en tous
les cas la pénalisation comme c'est le
cas à l'heure actuelle non appliquées
ouais là pas de sens
benoît delépine moustiques merci donc
j'ai bien vendu votre bouquin la save à
eux donc alors voila voila un voilà non
je n'ai absolument rien a ajouté ahmed a
ajouté avec nous oui selon varsovie